as the lockdown is being lifted we are
slowly starting to return to our busy
lives here to make things a little
easier
is lifestyle expert sema cohen hi sima
nice to see you jc
always great having you in studio
because you always bring amazing
products what do you have for us today
all right jc today we have ob fragrance
hope in french means beginning and this
brand was created out of the desire to
help us live fresh
every day in our daily routine and
lifestyle
these days we need hand sanitizer right
what do you think
and this is unlike any other hand
sanitizer out there
first of all it was made in korea and
they use super
high moisture to keep it um to let
allow your hands to be soft and to not
dry out because we need to use it over
and over again they use plant extract
to keep it like that and here we have
their
a perfume refresher this is fantastic
because it's all natural it has no
chemicals it's allergy free it's fda
approved and the best part
it removes odors and what i love about
it
that you can use it on everything it's
not just for the body you can spray it
on your clothes
you can sprain on your sheets laundry
everything
really really fantastic and versatile
and those are all natural i love it to
this episode
it smells so fresh too the smell is
coming my way it smells so good
so delicate and fresh right what else is
on the table there all right
akira bella yakira bella is a modern
clothing line
that was created for women with the idea
in mind that
it's okay to be conservative trendy and
comfortable
at very affordable prices i love all of
the
collections why because they're
versatile and you can mix it up you can
dress it up you can dress it down
you can even wear some for daytime some
for night time
customize it the way you like it what i
also love about you kira bella that they
are big on giving back
they partner with our orphanage in
ukraine
and they donate to breast cancer
awareness awesome and then i see you've
got some juices on the table with you
hey this is in honor of you j.c i love
my juices and shots
yeah suzia is an organic non-gmo cold
pressed juice company located in san
diego california
they carry wide variety of juices
kombuchas and wellness shots
and what i love about them is they use
they utilize a method that's called
cold pressure method that helps preserve
all the vitamins and nutrients
in each and every one of their products
so we
get more vitamins and more nutrients and
also
sushi they constantly donate back they
give
they donate to communities to school to
social events
really really fantastic company love
them i love these products you have that
are giving
back and i love those juices we saw on
the table stuff for immunity stuff for
your good gut health so many great
things there
what's the final product you brought for
us today sadaf product
sadaf is a family-owned company that's
been around for over 30 years
they take pride in making products that
are natural
wholesome and as close to homemade as
possible
that's what i love about them and they
have thousands of items that you cannot
find
anywhere else i chose for us today
the organic teas this is the newest
released
you can drink it hot you can drink it
cold and they have
many different uh not
delicious flavors looks so good in the
key you say you can drink it hot you can
drink it cold
sema thank you so much for joining us
real quick what's the instagram handle
again
see my cohen official thank you so much
we appreciate it
all right